[Musique]
une brochette de stars en ouverture du
62ème festival de cannes
bill murray adam driver tilda swinton et
selena gomez
tous réunis par le cinéaste jim jarmusch
pour un film hors norme dont lui seul a
le secret des tonnes d'ail les morts ne
meurent pas de gauche
un film de zombies ou plutôt qu'une
parodie de films de zombies avec tous
les clichés du genre
une critique sociale aussi un regard
décalé sur la société de consommation
cannes cette année
ces 21 films en compétition officielle
et la sélection s'annonce comme un grand
cru
à tel point que le président du jury le
mexicain alejandro gonzalez inarritu
c'est un choix très complexe pour la
palme d'or
j'ai toujours trouvé la compétition
difficile et cette année il y a tant de
films de grands réalisateurs que ça va
amener à des débats intenses et
passionné dit il parmi les grands noms
on trouve des habitudes festival de
cannes comme coin tin tin tin oo déjà
primé pour patrick chesnais 94 qui
essaiera 25 ans plus tard d'obtenir une
nouvelle palme d'or avec once upon a
time
[Musique]
autre fidèle du festival les frères
dardenne déjà détenteur de deux palmes
d'or essaierons d'en ravir une 3e avec
un film d'actualité
la radicalisation d'un jeune musulman le
film s'appelle le jeune ahmed
vétéran de cannes avec 18 présences le
britannique ken loach visera lui aussi
une troisième palme d'or avec sorry we
miss you reste bien sûr un autre enfant
chérie de cannes xavier dolan ces
marches ce tapis rouge
xavier dolan les connais bien il va
aller fouler à nouveau le 22 mai
prochain pour présenter son nouveau film
mathias et maxime avec l'espoir bien
évidemment de décrocher enfin la palme
d'or mais ce ne sera pas facile car
cette année la concurrence est rude
ici jean françois bélanger radio-canada
calme